und wenn ich gefragt werde wer der
größte held der wiedervereinigung sei
bush kohlenstoff oder sonst jemand
nachts dann sage ich in anerkennung
unserer gewissen verdienste
das deutsche volk und das russische volk
waren mit ihm die mini
sehr berührende worte von gorbatschow
und mobile hat sind wir heute auch
mitgebracht als das thema des tages ja
zehn jahre war es damals hier dass die
mauer gefallen war besondere würdigung
vornehmlich wirtschaft vor dem deutschen
bundestag damals schon reichstag in
berlin
was mich aber viel mehr bewegt hat war
gestern als die nachricht kam blickte
auf twitter und da war das einzige was
kam dieser werbespot den wiedersehen für
pizza hat also alles war 20.000 30.000
suisse gab es über pizza hut und michael
gorbatschow das war nicht nur ein gag
sondern war auch eine politische
botschaft die zugleich 1000 fahrten mit
transportiert wurde dieser mann so hieß
es da hat nicht nur sein reich ruiniert
das erwähnt reicht sondern sich dann an
den westen verkauft inklusive diese
skizze an videos kann das war hat mich
sehr überrascht fand ich sehr ungerecht
weil es eine historische größe war und
ist die wir mit michael gorbatschow und
der wird in keiner weise dem bereich
presse für deutschland geleistet hat und
für die welt denn ohne gorbatschow
hättest nie diese öffnung gegeben in der
sowjetunion also perestroika hättest
auch kein glas ausgegeben ohne
gorbatschow hätte es wir haben es
gesehen am rande bregenz mutige
ansprachen uhr gegeben als spruch hier
in berlin vor 35 jahren mit der
gorbatschow open this gate und
es wäre nichts daraus gefolgt und ohne
gorbatschow hätte es ich nehme an sicher
in der nacht vom neunten auf den zehnten
november
1989 irgendwann dann doch den
schießbefehl gegeben als nämlich
tausende von mutigen bürgern dann eine
indirekte aufforderung wahrgenommen
haben und daneben die grenzen gestürmt
haben ja und auch das muss man sagen
auch gorbatschow hatte seine dunklen
seiten es war nämlich
kaum ein jahr im amt da passierte
tschernobyl ein reaktor block
explodierte die server jetzt haben
damals alles unter den teppich gekehrt
die ukraine damals gehörte ja nach dem
sowjetreich und haben uns hier im
dunklen gelassen was die wahren
auswirkungen angeht tausende von
menschen starben dort an diesen
radioaktiven verseuchungen
auch dafür war verantwortlich er hat
aber daraus die konsequenz gezogen und
gesagt gelassen hast ich gehe jetzt
offen damit um
und viel wichtiger ist was er geschaffen
hat ohne gorbatschow und ohne seinen mut
ohne seinen willen hätte es keine
deutsche einheit gegeben und dafür
schulden wir ihm für immer
dankbar
ja da gibt es nichts weiter dazu sagen
es gibt natürlich jetzt noch zu
debattieren wie jetzt das begräbnis
aussehen wird von herr gorbatschow und
da ist natürlich die frage der cdu chef
friedrich merz hat er schon gefordert
dass alle staatschefs dahin reisen
werden ist das in der aktuellen lage
überhaupt möglich wie version begräbnis
vor dem ukraine krieg gewesen wie wir
das jetzt sein
naja das ist erstmal die frage des
ausrichters wenn man zu nehmen kann und
wenn es ein staatsbegräbnis wird dann
würde natürlich der russische staat und
diesem fall der russische präsident
darüber entscheidet das interessante ist
ja
in russland selbst nicht nur bei putin
war gorbatschow ja nicht unumstritten
ganz im gegenteil viele menschen werfen
ihm bis heute vor dass ihr das
sowjetreich zerstört hat durch seine art
und durch sein irgendwann gar nicht
handeln das wird nicht von allen als
kämpfer für die demokratie wahrgenommen
sondern eben in russland auch von vielen
anders gesehen aber und gleichzeitig hat
er immer bis zuletzt für ein dialog
geworben mit russland auch unter putin
also obwohl putin und er sicherlich man
kann sagen verfeindet waren hat auch
gorbatschow bis zuletzt gesagt gebt das
reden miteinander nicht auf also die ur
idee der diplomatie die von hans
dietrich genscher gott hab ihn selig
immer so verkörpert wurde egal wie die
zeiten waren aber es und kalter krieg
war da sonst also muss man sehen wie die
entscheidung wird sollte es ein solches
staatsbegräbnis geben dann geht die
einladung natürlich an das
staatsoberhaupt denke ich oder an den
regierungschef und da muss man sich
darauf einlassen und natürlich wäre es
an gemessen wenn deutschland der
hochrangigste repräsentiert wurde und
der bundespräsident und der
bundeskanzler dahin fahren würden klar
wie hoch ist die wahrscheinlichkeit dass
es möglich sein wird das kann ich nicht
voraus in den russischen medien war der
tod von gorbatschow den russischen
medien wirklich nur 1 10 sekündige
ansage dass herr gorbatschow tod es wird
keine doku keine lange rede wirklich
einfach nur dass er gestorben ist
dementsprechend ist wahrscheinlich die
wahrscheinlichkeit niedriger dass es ein
großes staatsbegräbnis wird mit
staatschefs wie gesagt er war da kein
held dass das muss man einfach so sehen
auch in den meisten bei dem beim
großteil der bevölkerung nicht hier ist
ja auch uns natürlich ein begriff bei
jüngeren menschen noch nicht so wird
seiner rolle nicht gerecht und
vielleicht ist aber auch eine
gelegenheit zu sagen wir russischen
staates wir gucken mal wer kommt in
einer solchen phase der preis darf würde
denn die fdp-spitze würden sie den
vorschlag unterstützen von herr merz
dass sie hin reisen sollten ich glaube
man muss tatsächlich erst einmal schauen
ob das begräbnis von michael gorbatschow
für putin ein solches ereignis über
werden wird ich glaube nicht dass es zu
seiner agenda passt
gorbatschow steht für werte wie putin
nicht teilt für ein offenes russland für
ein russland der öffnung auch zum westen
hin dass er genau wie gegenbewegungen
die putin jetzt macht und warum sollte
an dieser situation der sich jetzt
gerade befindet in einem krieg der nicht
läuft er wo er in einem sehr vagen
situation sich befindet warum sollte er
da jemanden groß ehren der genau für die
entgegensetzen werte steht jetzt wurde
damit würde sich sicherlich eine flanke
auf machen und ich glaube dass wir hier
auch grundsätzlich guckt müssen wenn sie
eine einladung kommt wie wir das auch im
europäischen kontext handhaben wie wir
das mit unseren partnern zusammen machen
ich glaube das ist keine zeit für
alleingänge ist sie muss man sich
gemeinsam auch im europäischen rahmen
abstimmen wünscht man sich nicht
manchmal als bürger auch politiker die
auch mal nach dem herzen entscheiden
also wenn ich jetzt an einen herrn
genscher beispielsweise denke muss man
nicht mal überlegen ob man es dann
machen sollte ohne vielleicht alle
europäischen partner erst mal zu fragen
ja politik ist ja doch immer ein
bisschen mehr als nur das herz es ist
halt auch verstand und das ist auch
viele zusammenhänge die ich beachten
muss und wir finden uns gerade einer
großen krise und wir haben auch mit
russland gemeinsam eine große krise und
da kann man nicht business as usual
machen ich glaube wäre das vor zwei
jahren passiert ist ein staatsbegräbnis
gegeben hätte sich gar keiner gefragt ob
man da entweder wir selbstverständlich
verständlich gewesen wir können den tod
auch nicht leer aus dem kontext reisen
und auch eine solche veranstaltung nicht
und ich finde natürlich märz auch nicht
angebracht ehrlich gesagt dieses thema
zu nutzen um politische spielchen zu
treiben denn das ist gefährlich das
macht keinen sinn
von béla anda gehört steht noch gar
nicht fest in welchem rahmen auch das
staatsbegräbnis stattfindet also wenn
friedrich merz gesagt sie sollten
hinreisen ist ja kein politisches spiel
ist heute noch niemand abgesagt jetzt
schon natürlich ein aufbau von der druck
kulisse ja das ist erwartungen zu äußern
natürlich erwarte ich dass die
bundesregierung dorthin reist damit baue
ich ja schon etwas aufnehmen und
probiere eine erzählung auch aufzubauen
vielleicht die die in diesem fall aus
meiner sicht nicht angemessen ist ich
finde das ist eine form des respekts
unser land ist eine einheit das
verdanken wir vor allen dingen diesen
mann dieser mann den schießbefehl
gegeben denn viele menschen gestorben
das wäre nie dazu bekommen all das was
wir heute sind
eine nation ein land verdanken wir
diesen mann und es ist eine form des
respekts klar wenn putin dass dort nicht
machen sollte vielleicht überrascht er
uns aber macht sowas dann sollte unser
politische spitze und besonders stolz
der gerade in so einer krise ist als
wahrscheinlich schon wieder vergessen
hat sollte sich vielleicht überlegen das
vielleicht zu nutze und wenn er das
nicht macht dann sollte er sich vor
kanzler anstellen und vielleicht die
fahne hissen oder zumindest denken dass
man diesen mandant öffentlich dank für
das was er gemacht hat denn nochmal wir
alle da waren wir noch klären wir waren
da noch klinisch suchen ja da da sollten
wir dankbar sein dass wir heute drin
sind übrigens man nur davon abgesehen
mainz nebenbei meine kinder sind zur
hälfte polnisch ich hätte diese kinder
gar nicht wenn dieser mann gewesen wäre
und deshalb dass dieser respekt ihm
gegenüber sehr sehr wichtig ist ich weiß
politische spielchen sind ja normal es
geht ja immer nur politik aber
menschlichkeit ist der was du denn ich
will euch dort nur noch einmal in
erinnerung rufen die würde des menschen
ist unantastbar
ja aber aber soll man in einer situation
in der russische truppen
kriegsverbrechen in der ukraine beginnt
ein staatsbegräbnis beiwohnen wo ich
neben russischen soldaten deutsche
regierungsmitglieder stehen
ein g20 gipfel haben in wenigen wochen
persien da kommen die 20
wirtschaftsstärksten nationen dieser
welt und logische präsident hat
angekündigt ich fahr dahin ja ja ist ja
kein und machen es ist keine russischen
staatsbegräbnis
schulter und sagen da müssen wir uns
erstmal im europäischen an einer das von
ihm die pizza hut was bassum stehen zu
lassen finde ich gut mein sohn heute
frage weiß ja nicht wer ist zeigt mir
schon wieder wie die geschichte auch in
den schulen teilweise vermittelt wird
hat wird ja aber sie kann ebenso ein
beibringen was sicher nachweisen
er weiß warum wir heute warum wir heute
diese freiheit hat die andere in dem
land mit anderen ländern nicht mehr
hatte die verdanken wir ihm punkt das
ist deren bürger dass sie dann die
wiedervereinigung in deutschland erlebt
und auch herr gorbatschow die rolle sagt
ja ich meine noch zu wissen dass wir
damals zu der zeit sogar in berlin waren
mit der mannschaft und mir dann selber
noch eine mauer waren und steine
rausgeschlagen haben das weiß ich noch
habe ich jetzt noch im gedächtnis und
wenn das nicht passiert wäre dann hätte
ich meine frau nicht kennengelernt und
sie ist aus ostberlin und wir sind
verheiratet wir haben eine tochter und
ich kann nur mein hut davor ziehen was
die damaligen herren herr gorbatschow
und herr kohl gemacht haben und das
finde ich einfach klasse und bin froh
dass das damals absolut passiert ist
also ließen sich also dem appell anfang
eine andere ja ich habe da immer
probleme mit es wird immer alles tot
geredet es wird immer alles kaputt
geredet man kann doch einfach mal das
herz entscheiden lassen und die gefühle
entscheiden lassen da ist natürlich
schwer für viele die politik treiben ja
die auch aus meiner sicht mit denen ich
zu tun habe realitätsfern sind das
beschäftigt mich seit vielen jahren
einsatz vorhin noch meine mutter nicht
vor zwei wochen angerufen und sagte
weißt du ich habe es mal durchgerechnet
ich habe jetzt schon 100 euro weniger im
monat da kriege ich denn da laufen wir
die trennende zu hause die tränen
gelaufen diese menschen werden vergessen
unsere kinder werden vergessen und wir
haben nur immer irgendwelche ideen
fahren wir dahin haben wir das haben wir
dass die probleme haben wir hier hier
haben wir die probleme und das ist für
mich etwas wo ich wirklich ein riesiges
problem